welcome back when problem number seven
problem number seven if a and B are
positive integers and a squared minus B
squared is equal to seven a squared
minus B squared is equal to seven what
is the value of a so it says that a and
B are positive integers and a squared
minus B squared is equal to seven so
there's a couple of ways that i would i
would think about this you could say
well this is actually the way i would
think about it whenever I see a
something squared minus something I
immediately just want to factor it let's
see what we're that that gets us you get
that a plus B times a minus B is equal
to seven and we know that a and B are
our positive integers so we know that
that both of these what we don't know
for sure that well we know this is going
to be a positive integer right you add
to positive integers you definitely get
a positive integer and we also know that
this is going to be a positive integer
how do I know that well when I multiply
a positive integer time something and I
get another positive integer or get
another positive number I know that
whatever I x is positive right because
the positive times a positive is
positive so what does this say so these
are both positive integers and they when
I multiply them I get seven so what
could they be well what number is when
you multiply it can be seven well
there's there's only two choices right 1
times 7 because 7 is prime there's 7 has
no other factors other than one and
seven so which one is going to be seven
at which one is going to be one well the
larger one is going to be seven right
the larger ones going to be seven and
the small ones going to be one though
you could eyeball this you could say
well what to number is when i add them
together seven and when i subtract them
i get one and you can meet least you
know you could say well what if a is for
b is three then that works for plus 3 is
7 4 minus 3 is 1 and a few that didn't
just dawn on you all of a sudden you
could do a system of equation a plus b
is equal to 7 a minus b is equal to 1
add these two equations you get to a the
bees cancel out right
plus 0 is equal to 8 7 plus 1 is 8 a is
equal to 4 and you can substitute back
in or you know just play around with the
numbers and you get B is equal to 3 so
that is choice oh they want to just know
what a is so a is for which is choice B
B next problem we have a number line
here draw it nice and big don't know how
much space i'll need have 0 in the
middle 0 in the middle negative 1 and 1
let me draw these points now t UV and w
u v w and then you have x or x and y
here then you have z
on the number line above which of the
following corresponds to the absolute
value absolute value of u minus V and
this is just an approximation problem
you might get intimidated I how do I
figure out v well the answer is you just
kind of guess when you don't guess you
approximate so let's see what what does
you look like well you looks like I
don't know if you eyeballing it looks
like minus point eight if i were to
eyeball it may be a little more minus
point eight five let's call right
because almost at negative 1 but not all
the way there I don't think its nine
tenths there but it's uh yeah I would
say minus point 85 I'm just eyeballing
it so let's just say u is equal to minus
point eight five and what's v.v looks
about two thirds on the way to you so
let's say V is equal to minus point six
once again I'm just let's say minus
point six six just to be you know I'm
just approximating once again so it's
minus right and they're both negative
numbers and they're both almost at one
so what is the absolute value of u minus
V well that's the absolute value of
minus 0 point eight five minus V so
minus minus point six six so that's the
minus minus becomes a plus so what's
minus point eight five plus point six
six well that's roughly roughly minus
point 19 and if I'm taking the absolute
value of that that becomes 0 point one
9.19 roughly a fifth and you know
there's no other number around you know
roughly a fifth is around here and
there's no other number there even
remotely close so that's going to be X
and another way you could have thought
about that if you didn't want to
approximate and use numbers i do that
just to make sure the absolute value
that when you subtract two numbers and
you take the absolute value your sensor
you say well what's the distance between
the two what's the positive distance i
don't care one larger is less than the
other so you're essentially saying
what's this distance this distance here
that's equal to this to do this
expression so that distance that
positive distance is approximately equal
to x even in my non exact drawing and if
you look at if you
look at how they do it actually even
even in the way they drew it oh sorry
they did you they did you- w so then it
actually makes even more sense because W
is more like point five so I've misread
the problem this w is equal to more like
point five so the absolute value of u
minus u minus W is going to be equal to
the absolute value point eight five
sorry w z is minus point five right is
in the negative domain so minus point
eight five minus point five so that
equals minus point 35 absolute values
equal 2.35 still is equal to x and they
did that you know I was just
approximating that X still works but
according to the drawing it makes even
more sense because we're actually
talking about this distance sorry 2w let
me do it in a different better color
this is what you not this this is what
this represents the absolute value of u
minus W represents this distance and if
you were to that distance is the same as
the value of x and it really makes sense
if you just look at the distance between
U and W on the in the book it's almost
exact it this actually looks like it was
drawn to scale next problem and that's
choice C either way even when I did
wrong the first way I didn't do it wrong
I misread to give myself a little bit of
credit all right problem number nine
although you won't get much credit if
you miss read when you take it okay a
number n is increased by 5 and is in I
write these out as our reedom is
increased by 5 and the result is x 5 the
result is x 5 this result is decreased
by five finally that result is divided
by five the whole result is divided by
five in terms of n what is the final
result well what can we do here we can
divide the numerator and denominator by
5 so this 5 will cancel out with this
and this right because you distribute so
you're left with
n plus 5 times 1 right because it just
becomes a 1 this becomes a 1 this
becomes a 1 n plus 5 FN plus 5 times 1 I
won't write the one because it matter
anymore minus 1 all of that over 12 to
ignore that so it's n plus 5 minus 1
well it's n plus 4 all right just go to
the parentheses plus five minus one is n
plus 4 and so that's choice D see if I
have space to the next problem actually
or time ash more than space I will
actually wait to do to the next video
just so I don't rush things which I tend
to do see you soon